- 'Cause you're also in another big movie,
Marvel's "The Eternals".
You were talking about
that at the beginning
and are you scared of
accidentally spoiling it?
'Cause I feel like they're
like pretty hardcore
on people, right?
- Well, there are five
Marvel people standing
behind my computer right now.
(laughing)
You know what, it was
such an amazing time.
There was a part of my
life where I never thought
that I would ever get to see
myself reflected back to me.
And most of the parts that I've played,
to be the quirky scientist
and Godzilla, you know,
and then to be a superhero,
I just never thought it would happen.
And I am incredibly, incredibly grateful
to Marvel for allowing
me to play a character
that reflects me back to me.
And being able to work with Chloe Zhao
who is blowing up, her eye is one
of the most amazing eyes I've ever seen.
Big ups to her on
"Nomadland" and you know,
the work she's doing.
And I just am really excited for the world
to see exactly where
we're taking this universe
'cause it's unlike anything
you've ever experienced or seen.
And it's a beautiful thing to
see representation up there.
So I'm glad to be a part of it.
- Absolutely and I am a
total nerd for Marvel.
Like I, I'm like,
"Oh yeah, my kids and I
are gonna watch this."
My kids will like jet like
10 minutes in the movie
and I am like.
(audience laughing)
- What's your go-to?
Who's your go-to, who's
your go-to Marvel person?
- Dr Strange is currently my favorite.
- Okay then.
All right.
- I know, I like Dr Strange.
You know why?
I like his power.
I think his power is really rad.
That's the thing.
- Wait until you see my powers.
They're, I don't wanna give nothing away
'cause like I said, Marvel's
standing right here,
but--
(audience laughing)
- Okay, okay, I'm excited.
- Mine are pretty dope.
I wanna see my cosplay
from you at one point.
I want you--
- Okay, okay.
You better bring it.
You better bring your A game.
(laughing)
You're fricken powers.
- It's already brought, Kelly Clarkson.
It's already brought.
- I'm like, you better not suck.
Just kidding.
(laughing)